voters giving the squad a major scare
over their radical policies ilhan omar
narrowly surviving a primary battle
against a moderate pro-police democrat
omar squeaking out a win by a measly 3
000 votes according to projections her
opponent actually ran in part because of
how fed up he was with omar's efforts to
defund the police
greg gutfeld
she's squeaked by yeah
are you are you happy that she's still
in congress are you a little different i
mean look the race was as close as ilhan
and her brother oh
but this is i mean she's still one we
just got to hope that the republicans
right come up with something you know
that can fight with this district yeah
never mind
um
omar's a very depressing story for me in
american politics you know who saved her
life was basically the american system
right she she was in uh she was in a
refugee camp and she
you know she came to america i guess in
1995 and became a citizen
and all she does is rail against the
american system and i can't believe that
that's how she felt when she was in a
refugee camp so somewhere along the
lines and i don't think it's from
somalia either somewhere along the lines
before she
when she got here to now she was
radicalized where was she radicalized at
north dakota state university i think is
where she went but it also bothers me
that pro progressives always have an
edge why she won the work to remake
society is never done because you create
situations like defunding and rioting
which creates misery and unrest and when
they and when that happens you go see
our work is far from done so they as
they keep their constituents in misery
they can always promise to be the
solution to the misery do you think that
the voters themselves are to blame a
little bit though i mean they vote for
people then those people defund the
police then the crime rate surges and
then people get shot anyway let's just
elect the same person i think it's very
hard to beat an incumbent and this guy
that tried to go against her was more of
a moderate democrat had been a supporter
of hers and said you know what the
defund the police went too far for him
so he was going to give give it a shot
but she raises so much money yeah and
the thing is she's become very useful
and the white house has shown they care
a lot more about people like ilhan omar
than they do abigail spanberger
for example i would wanted to tell you
today they just announced that the
the democrats on the house side have
decided they will not take up the police
bill that the the moderate democrats
wanted she was a sponsor of that they're
not even going to bother to bring it up
so when when they say we didn't save her
for defunding the police remind them of
that and about abigail oh poor abigail
so the squad
god you must be so sick of these people
does omar ever say anything good about
this country do you remember the last
thing she said
no but i'm i'm sure it exists
pull the tape yeah no i'm sure well she
has talked about how only in this
country it's possible to greg's point
that you could come here as a refugee
agency
and then she said that yeah she said
destroy it
so i'm not a you know my politics are
not aligned with the far left side of my
party and i don't know anyone who
actually wasn't excited about the fact
that she might lose her primary last
night and it's predicted that by 2024
she actually will lose so it's inching
towards being able to beat her and i
don't know if you saw
the documentary the netflix documentary
about the progressives that had aoc and
it was corey bush and the woman who was
challenging joe manchin and everyone in
it lost but aoc and it is not a winning
formula unless you are in the bluest of
areas to be running around saying the
stuff that the squad is saying it
doesn't win elections abigail spanberger
and mikey cheryl and those people are
the ones that are winning tough
elections and
we have we should be supporting those
kinds of policies okay we call her abby
now yeah
i did i say happy i call her spam it's
bad yeah all right judge i know you have
uh
you love the omar you and omar you guys
go way back
yes indeed johanna and i have a history
yes you do have a history yes i have
found that there's very little she said
that is uh pro-american but i'll leave
it at that okay oh no i'm not done i'll
leave that point at that all right look
she ran against the guy who was pro-law
enforcement she's defund the police
she's running in a democratic district
against someone who is a republican and
it's heavily democratic it looks like
obviously that she's going to win but i
think that as we go forward more and
more as everyone it seems have been
saying the progressives are losing and i
think that uh maybe she might not win in
the next term and by the way i know her
history pretty well i've never heard her
say anything pro-american anything
positive about the country that saved
her gave there the ability to leave a
war-torn area uh and get an education uh
and uh be a success
all right and you heard it this is our
prediction she will be the first squad
member to be booted from congress omar
we agree we all agree
you said it the liberal section hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else